-You've been so great to me.
You've Zoomed into the show
a bunch of times to help me out.
And I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
To see you in person,
it makes me so happy.
-Thank you.
You've been there for me since
the beginning of my career.
-No, is that true?
When was that? Awhile.
-Yes, for a long time.
-You just recently
celebrated your birthday.
-I did. My 25th birthday.
-Thank you.
-Happy 25th, of course!
-Thank you. Thank you.
-You had a surprise party,
is what I heard.
-I did.
Do you like surprise parties?
-Did you enjoy it?
-I love surprise parties.
It's just really hard
to surprise me.
-It is?
-Yeah, I'm a Virgo, and...
-[ Gasps ] Me, too!
[ Cheering ]
-Hey, that's why we --
See? Oh, look at that.
-Wow.
-Twins.
[ Laughter ]
We'll be like why couldn't we --
[ Laughing ]
Virgos.
But, I, it is...
[ Laughter ]
It is very hard to surprise me,
because I am very nosy
and I can hear a pin drop.
-Yeah, you can.
-So I can literally,
I can hear my assistant
in the back right now,
while I'm talking to you.
-Yeah?
-I can hear her.
-So how did they do it?
-I was very busy.
It was Fashion Week.
So I had a huge, big schedule,
and they threw in some fitting,
some random fitting,
and I was upset about it,
because I was like,
"Who has a fitting at 7:00 PM?"
-Yeah.
-You know?
And so I was like,
"I'm going to wear this."
And she was like, "No!
You have to wear the dress
that your stylist sent!"
And I was like,
"What? It's a fitting!"
So I cooperated,
and I'm glad I did,
'cause they got me.
They got me good.
-So you go into this thing.
Were you in a bad mood?
-I was a little sour,
because I'm going to wardrobe
fitting at 7:00 PM.
Like, y'all couldn't
do this earlier?
-Yeah, and then you walk in...
-And I walk and they're like,
"Surprise!"
And I was like --
rr, eeh, ahh!
Like, I was...
-You had real heavy emotions.
-I was happy. Yeah.
I was happy but I was mad,
'cause they got me.
-But you said,
happy to see everybody.
Well, happy, happy birthday.
-Thank you.
-You look gorgeous tonight.
Say it again. What else?
-You always look gorgeous.
-Oh.
-This is you
at the Met Gala, by the way.
Look at this. Fantastic.
-Oh, that was amazing.
-Look at this, now. Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone was
talking about this.
-Were they?
-Oh, yeah. Are you kidding me?
You were in all the fashion
magazines, you had the papers.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-I don't pay attention
to that stuff
'cause I don't want
my feelings hurt,
so I just take the picture
and I never look back.
-Oh, no,
these were all great stuff.
-Okay, good.
-What was the theme this year
at the Gala?
-It was Hollywood Glamour.
Old Hollywood glamour.
I just decided
to tap into Diana Ross,
because I just love her so much.
-I love Diana Ross.
-She embodies glamour.
-Come on. Right?
-Yeah.
-That Central Park show
is the one I always think about.
The wind, and the yeah,
and it was raining.
Oh, she's unbelievable.
-Class act.
-There's so many famous people
you meet at the Gala.
Who'd you hang with?
-Well, you know I saw Mary,
so...
-[ Gasps ] I love Mary J. Blige.
-That's my bestest friend
in the industry, yes.
-I love Mary.
-And so I saw her,
and then we ran into
Meg Thee Stallion.
-[ Gasps ] My other...
-Y'all know that's my baby girl.
She put me in her video,
"Body-ody-ody."
-That's right, she did.
-She's the best.
She's funny.
-And then she was intrigued
with the...
Well, there was certain
parts of our bodies
that was showing in our...
Well, okay, so mine,
in the back,
it had a dip in the back,
as well, and so I had --
-Deeper than this dip?
-See that dip, there?
-Yes.
-It was in the back as well.
So it was like,
a little, sexy plumber's crack.
[ Laughter ]
And then Mary's dress
was kind of revealing, too.
-Sexy plumber's crack?
-Yeah.
-That's so funny.
-So what she did is she posts,
she put us on her Story
and she was like, "Ooh,
that sexy butt crack."
-Are you recording
anything with Megan?
Ahh
-Ooh. What did you hear?
-Well, I don't know.
I know that you can sing.
And I heard that you actually
were working on
a little EP or something.
-It's crazy,
because it found me.
Like, I didn't go seeking it.
I was looking for a song
for one thing that I was doing,
and so I reached out
to some producer friends I know,
and then they sent me these
incredible beats and I was like,
"Well, how do I pick one?
I'll just do an EP."
-Do all of them.
Look at you.
-But I'm telling you, listen,
I was not looking for music.
It found me --
first in "The Muppets" --
if you saw the
"Muppets Haunted Mansion,"
I sang in that.
And then the next thing,
Miss Hannigan.
There's something else
I'm being tapped for right now,
but I can't say anything
until the ink dries.
-Wow, really?
-And it really involves music.
-[ Gasps ]
-And then my EP.
It's just like,
"What are you doing?"
-I'm so happy for you, though,
because I know you can do it.
Do you know when it's going
to come out or no?
-Top of the year. Stay tuned.
-Okay. Alright.
January. Taraji P. Henson.
I'm just saying,
look out for something good.
I'm talking about "Annie"
right now.
-Okay.
-This is Miss Hannigan.
Look at you.
[ Applause ]
Come on.
So, wait, how's it going?
-So much fun.
-Great cast.
-Great. I mean, dynamic.
Just wait until
you see these little --
I call them my biscuits
and my little cookies
and my little ladybugs.
-Yeah.
-The little orphans.
Oh, my God. They're so amazing.
And Celina is going to
blow you away, our Annie.
-Really?
-Harry is a pain in my butt.
-Harry Connick Jr.?
-No, I love him. He's amazing.
He has this Southern drawl
that just, you're like,
"Say something again, Harry."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, right?
Oh, I love him so much.
-He's so incredible.
-But the book,
the music on this is just...
-You know what's
amazing about this play?
The subject matter.
They're talking about
the Great Depression
and Broadway opening back up.
Does that sound familiar
to you guys?
-Yeah, it's eerie, right?
-It's very eerie.
-Yeah.
What is your big number?
-Oh, I have "Little Girls."
I have "Sign." "Easy Street."
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, and "Sign" is
with Harry Connick and I.
That's our duet.
-Okay.
-And then I have "Little Girls."
That's Miss Hannigan's solo.
And then we have "Easy Street."
-This thing is live.
-It's live.
-Are you nervous at all?
-Of course.
Nerves are good, though.
-Yeah, they are.
-If you're not nervous,
I'm concerned.
Nerves means you're alive.
You're in the moment.
You're right here in the moment.
-Yes!
-They're to be used.
-That's exactly right.
-Absolutely.
-I cannot wait for
this performance
and I love you so much.
We're doing more
with Taraji P. Henson.
Come back.
More "Tonight Show," everybody.